peu
j'écoute l'année
tout petit vous aimiez déjà la belle
musique vous vous laissiez inondées et
petit à petit vous est demandé d'où ça
venait comment ça se faisait
j'ai commencé à faire le tour du poste à
chercher un petit peu à comprendre et
vous avez même fait des expériences
ensuite vous avez construit vous même
votre poste à galène avec tous les
appareils avec les brochures que vous
étiez procurer tout cela vous a coûté
bien du temps mais du temps dont vous
vous réjouissez encore maintenant
c'était tellement amusant vous écoutiez
la musique ça n'était pas toujours très
très beau ce que vous écoutiez vous
entendiez surtout beaucoup de parasites
peut-être mais la joie d'avoir construit
soi même un poste vous bien les
imperfections de l'audition et puis ça a
été une révolution
la télévision et maintenant quand vous
sortez de l'école vous ne verrez pas une
occasion d'aller vous précipiter à la
vitrine des marchands télévision vous
regardez les programmes vous passionner
et vous vous dites que vous aimeriez
bien être de ceux qui fabriquent ces
images la première opération consiste
évidemment à filmer toute la partie
reportage de l'émission
il s'agit du tournage classique au moyen
d'une caméra de cinéma mais la matière
cinématographique ainsi obtenu n'est pas
encore prête pour la projection il faut
qu'elle passe par le montage on a tourné
une matière bien trop abondante chaque
plan était repris plusieurs fois sur les
indications du réalisateur il faut donc
choisir mettre de l'ordre
coupez recoller coupage et collages sont
les deux mamelles du montage et le
montage rejoint retrait important
puisque l'on compte environ quatre jours
de montage pour chaque émission de
chacun son métier
cette vente que nous possédons
maintenant prête à être projeté en tant
qu'image est muette
il importe encore de la sonorisé
enregistré dans un studio spéciale le
commentaire de l'image c'est monsieur
bernard qui va nous décrire ces
opérations de sonorisation et de
synchronisation
les commentateurs sont assis en face
d'un écran sur lequel on projette le
film image
l'ingénieur puissant de cailly rentrer
place
les deux commentateurs en face des
microphones c'est l'opération type à ses
heures voire bien diriger le micro en
face d'eux est également bien réglé la
directivité de la voie en face du
microphone et également les places et
une certaine distance pour avoir un plan
sonore bien réglée ils doivent donc
commencer par obtenir je suppose une
licence ou de lettres ou de sciences où
je serai une bonne formation
universitaire et ensuite qu'est ce que
vous faites alors de ses apprentis
voici dans la cabine c'est à dire de
l'autre côté de la vitre qui permet
d'isoler acoustiquement leçon direct par
rapport aux 100 témoins du haut parleur
l'ingénieur du son règles de niveau vous
pouvez le contrôlé au moyen du petit
module omex des petites églises au
centre d'accueil de la du pupitre qui
bat got et à gauche vous voyait le
projecteur 16 mm images qui projette à
travers la classe l'image des mois dont
les boutons pour régler le niveau il
faut pas ce niveau soit par ni trop fort
ni trop faible et nous voici en face de
la machine d'enregistrement c'est une
machine magnétophone 16 mm avec cette
particularité que c'est une bande
perforé beaucoup plus large que machines
d'enregistrement menchov homme ordinaire
qui a que 6 mm et qui permet tout de
même une reproduction de haute qualité
tout le problème c'est d'arriver un
parfait synchronisme c'est à dire que la
vente sont est une banque différente de
la pente images que vous non de voir des
files exactement à la même vitesse d'où
la complexité des états mariage tous ces
engrenages alors que pour un petit
magnétophone dictaphone qui est
maintenant très connu et part que tout
le monde a déjà vu
l'appareillage mécanique est beaucoup
plus simple et il faut arriver à avoir
non seulement un défilement de même
vitesse mais ce qui est encore bien plus
compliqué un déroulement parfaitement
homogène c'est à dire ne pas avoir de
plus rage pour que le son ne se met pas
un son de piano reste parfaitement et
une autre tenir est ce qu ils notent
bien tenu une licence ou de lettres ou
sciences humaines allègrement une
expérience très amusant d'écouter sa
propre voie
mais c'est aussi très utile pour se
corriger pour recommencer au besoin car
c'est là un des gros avantages du
magnétophone
sur place nous sommes maintenant dans la
grotte du cheval en train de faire leur
histoire est terminée
on va passer procéder maintenant on
rembobine âge c'est à dire de faire
tourner le film à l'envers et la tête
magnétique permet en même temps de
donner le sens témoin de ce sont à
l'envers c'est extrêmement amusant
d'ailleurs tout le monde connaît les
faits ne serait ce que par la musique
concrète et par les voisins l'envers
utilisez souvent maintenant la bande
sonore est prête elle vient rejoindre la
bande image au télé cinéma chaque bande
est monté sur sa bobine et un technicien
est là qui grâce à un appareil spécial
va s'occuper du bon fonctionnement du
déroulement synchrone des deux bandes
qui est évidemment très important il et
l'ice s'occupe uniquement de cela
pendant qu'un autre technicien lui
surveille la qualité l'image
il est là en somme avant tout pour en
assurer l'équilibré au moyen de boutons
qu'il règle et dont ils s'occupent
exclusivement
on n'imagine pas vous avez une activité
qui règne sur les studios au moment de
la préparation de l'émission et la
préparation des images voici par exemple
les caméras qui sont braqués et chacune
sur un personnage différent la caméra un
qui va vous prendre vous étiez nadu et
la caméra 2 qui est à gauche qui prend
elle une archéologue monsieur le
professeur grand la place dans le vol à
un électricien qui est en train de
régler son éclairage et vous oui vous
qui souffrez lancement et le direct à la
photographie qui en ce moment de ces
indications cas il s'agit de régler
le faisceau lumineux de telle façon que
l'éclairage ambiant soit de nature à
satisfaire les exigences des caméras
télévision comme cela et en même temps
que vous soyez décoller du fond oui là
je tombe à plat qui est en relief
voilà qui vaut d'obtenir voici la caméra
1 qui s'approche et qui fait sa mise au
point
le cameraman étaient les d'un assistant
était en train de descendre la caméra
pour la mettre à la hauteur voulue et
voici maintenant le sujet numéro 2
l'archéologue qui brille pas la caméra
numéro 2 qui elle aussi va se régler
elle se règle en sûrement voyez vous on
est en train de changer d'optique on
vient de changer d'objectif pour obtenir
un cadrage différents un plus gros plan
par exemple tout ça avec un degré
l'image est prête maintenant mais au
studio faut encore qu'elle suive tout un
parcours
c'est elle arrive aux équipes en val
imagé signaux électriques qui seront
pris par le tube de prise de vue qui est
à l'intérieur et caméras les signaux
arrive ici aux équipements et vous voyez
les techniciens qui sont à vannes
travail et aux réglages de cette image
voici le réglage biométrie en cadrage si
vous voulez les proportions du mal oui
c'est pas tout d'ailleurs il ya eu
également le contraste de l'image le
collage à leurs photographies mais finit
pas de photo il permet artistique d'une
certaine manière il faut deux seulement
lui avoir une très grande formation
technique mais également du goût pour
faire ce travail
c'est un autre technicien qui travaille
lui aussi sur les signaux
oui ça c'est la bête synchronisation
vous voyez se dessiner sur les
oscilloscopes les courbes représentent
at-il des signaux de synchronisation qui
vaut synchroniser les images et les
lignes lui aussi par une solide
formation à tous et maintenant il y
aussi un problème sont en demande et
monsieur bernard de nous en parler
dans le cas d'une émission en direct son
est pris en même temps que l'image ceci
nécessite une mise au point très très
poussée
l'ingénieur du son règle et trois
paramètres à savoir d'abord la mise en
place du microphone c'est-à-dire son
orientation par rapport à la source
sonore deuxièmement la distance de ce
micro par rapport à la source
et ensuite troisièmement la directivité
de la source par rapport au micro
ces trois paramètres détermine d'une
part le plan sonore c'est à dire la
distance apparent deuxièmement
l'intelligibilité du texte qui soit
musicale ou parler nous voici de l'autre
côté
et cette fois ci dans la régie monsieur
oui l'ingénieur du son en règle comme
tout à l'heure le niveau de la
modulation qui contrôle au moyen du
module omettre contre légalement haut
parleurs la qualité et donne des
instructions dans le studio
vous venez nous parler de la régie
monsieur bernard est ce que monsieur
leroi vrai nous préciser ce qu'est cette
régie ce qui s'y passe c'est le local
technique qui est en vue et direct du
studio et où le réalisateur que vous
voyez là donne des ordres aux caméras
avec lesquels il est relié par téléphone
par interphone le caméraman à ce moment
là fait l'image cadre l'image comme le
lui demande le réalisateur qui
conseiller dai en cela par la script qui
est à côté de lui et en contrôler les
éléments sur ces récepteurs qui lui
donne les différentes images qui sont
préparés qui sont prêtes à passer à
l'émission il a en régie devant lui
toutes les images virtuelles ans à ses
classes sur les images vous avez en haut
à droite par exemple images en
provenance du télé cinéma en bas à
gauche
la caméra un lui envoie l'image de
vous-même monsieur la loupe
oui et à droite l'image de du professeur
leroi gourhan et au centre ce blanc
représente ce qui passera tout à l'heure
oui il ya présenté rien pour l'instant
monsieur patriat gens voyaient leurs
électeurs du centre et le récepteur de
contrôler le récepteur sur lequel le
réalisateur qui vient de donner un ordre
à la caméra là qu'elle transmet
s'étendre à l'interprète et le
réalisateur en voix cette image de la
caméra en moyenne un potentiomètre sur
l'antenne et vous voyez maintenant
paraître images de la caméra au centre
c'est à dire sur le récepteur de
contrôle final même manoeuvre pour la
caméra 2 dont l'image est envoyé sur
antenne en moyenne à boutons cette fois
on peut faire l'âne ou l'autre et vous
la voyez nouveau remplacé la kb minage
de la cave
les bressans leroi gourhan intervient
maintenant c'est au salon du télé cinéma
est-ce que ça se fait de la même façon
et c'est à dire que la voyais à
l'intervention du chef des missions vous
voyez la haute rien dire attention top
de départ
et voici le télé cinéma qui se met en
route avec ces bandits mages et
bande-son et le réalisateur le
réalisateur en voix avait à nouveau avec
un bouton de l'image vous pouvez
constater que l'image du télé cinéma là
haut à droite et celles qui étaient
aussi sur le récepteur de contrôle cette
fois
alors ici nous sommes maintenant régie
finale où le chef de chaîne lui et
chargée du contrôle final de l'image
avant de revoir les méthodes
il reçoit les images des différents
studios de la rue cognacq-jay ou des
cars de reportage qui sont à l'extérieur
dans le cas de reportages extérieur et
notent les incidents ap en charge de
veiller à tout encore un technicien qui
avait un rôle bien particulier bien
défini et celui ci a également un rôle
bien la nuit celui ci les devants les
orbi de départ où l'image
mélanger le signal plus exactement de
l'image mélanger le signal vidéo
fréquence est contrôlé par luigi en
oscilloscopes ça c'est celle envers
gilles abry ça c'est l'envers du décor
c'est les câbles coaxiaux également les
lampes les concepteurs les résistances
mais tout ce qui fait penser très bon
que nous montrions saint-michel
bernoville puisque s'il devient un jour
techniciens de télévision c'est bien
l'image qui pourrait avoir sous les yeux
500 visas c'est au fond des âmes le côté
technique alors je considère à tort nous
sommes amusés avec un technicien a
compté le nombre de tubes qui était mis
en oeuvre pour une émission à deux
caméras en studio il y en avait 1047
vous garantit pas si fort et ça dépasse
1000 oui il ya aussi beaucoup de
techniciens y en a pas plus de 1000 mais
il y en a 20 ans alors veiller toute une
équipe
continuons à suivre l'image où les
signaux lumineux cesa alors voici les
câbles coaxiaux qui transportent
justement ces signaux vers la tour
eiffel à l'émetteur et voici est
éducable câble qui descend dans ces
gaines le long de l'immeuble pour aller
suivre dans un caniveau la rue de
l'université que vous voyez là dans un
charmant petit dessin avec eux l'avenue
rapp
l'avenue rapp la rue de montessuy il ya
une faute d'orthographe yade était à
monter suivre n'empêche pas le peuple
autochtone aman iman ont lutté ils
arrivent ils arrivent au champ de mars à
la tour eiffel au cuvier sud et il suit
spillé sud jusqu'au sommet vers les
émetteurs
[Musique]